[Música]
obrigado gente dá vontade de cantar toda
vez que bono vox se querem dar uma
esquentada antes faz assim ó tomtom
mariana bairro equipe nós pleno sua
eterna bem mas também maranhão fez e
desiguais foi melhor barollo do play é
valeu
eu estava achando que eu estava achando
a minha fala pouco organizada perto de
de tantos depoimentos bacanas
aí eu resolvi voltar lá atrás e e também
pensar e falar um pouco da trajetória
que me trouxe até esse palco é uma honra
eu tenho muito orgulho disso acho que é
muito legal
era um sonho então estou muito feliz de
vê los aqui eu comecei como cartunista
do jornal aos 17 anos de idade e fazer
carton para jornal de papel tem uma
coisa que existia no tempo do seu pai
que a gente usava para ler e depois
usava pra forrar o show fazer xixi em
cima né
hoje não faça isso com seu tablet mas os
jornais estão em extinção é verdade
é eu trabalhei muitos e muitos anos em
jornal entre como cartunista do jornal
primeira hora de uberlândia já acabou e
como cartunista chargista ganhava muito
mal eu fui pegando outras atividades no
jornal não tinha o curso de comunicação
social eu me formei em história bem
depois
mas eu fui seguindo uma carreira como
repórter como editor como editor chefe
até que veio esse fenômeno da internet o
tempo todo o projeto executivo de jornal
mas eu ainda continuava sendo o
cartunista parava todo dia às seis da
tarde para ir lá fazer o meu desenho e
eu gostava muito de brincar com animação
fazer animações é é um péssimo aluno
então pegava com aqueles livros
gosto de matemática fazendo o desenho na
borda do livro
alguém já viu que desenho animado que se
passa assim faz o homem palito que vem
que pula na boca do tubarão e faz é é
ele mexe ea então foram as minhas
primeiras experiências com animação
quando veio a internet estava no grupo
algar com um grupo grande de de
comunicação editon uma telefônica era o
dono do jornal
e eu fui colocado no grupo de trabalho
junto com engenheiros com um monte de
gente pra fazer uma uma certa projeção
do que seria o futuro com a internet na
área de telecomunicações porque ia
começar essa abertura que trouxe o
telefone é móvel para todo mundo saber
tudo o que acabou com um sistema
telebrás que era público e veio a livre
concorrência na telefonia que foi uma
coisa positiva para o país no sentido de
que eu me lembro do meu telefone
doméstico da minha casa o telefone fixo
era alugado por que era tão caro uma
linha telefônica que muita gente alugava
telefone bom mas continuei cartunista
ainda gap
eu adoro essa frase eu adoro essa frase
porque é o seguinte mãe da gap mostra um
poder de síntese que a língua inglesa
tem é muito legal eu vi a primeira vez
em londres não é porque lá onde
concentra no metrô de londres o tempo
todo tem uma voz em main dogan mãe da
gap está escrito no chão e da escrita na
parede e nada mais é do que o cuidado
com o espaço entre a plataforma eo
degrau do trem
agora dizer isso em três palavrinhas só
inglês e nós de uberlândia uberaba que a
gente possa ao buraco né
a gente resolver e assim também mas eu
tava no no bondinho do pão de açúcar
este ano passado e villa ainda gapnet em
português é quase uma bíblia para dizer
a mesma coisa cuidar com degradava mãe
da guerra e como cartunista é não sei se
vocês sabem como é que funciona a
ferramenta o mecanismo do humor ele é o
seguinte é nada mais é do que você pegar
o seu cérebro e passar uma pegadinha
eu te conduzir uma linha de raciocínio
você segue a linha de raciocínio
achei
afinal eu dou uma quebrado um twist seu
cérebro sentir aquele twist não é idiota
que tudo isso não representa perigo é
ele vai ter um riso e vai provocar o
riso involuntário em você porque vai
falar-se cartaz do ano e vai rir então o
cérebro do cartunista o tempo todo
fazendo conexões improváveis o tempo
todo quem mora comigo sofre com isso
porque assim são as conexões mais
improváveis do mundo e foi assim que vem
da placa-mãe da guerra pé no bondinho do
corcovado e obviamente fiz a ligação com
aérea que estamos vivendo dos dos
aplicativos de comunicação do tipo a
desaprovei cybook mestre de todos esses
que estão por aí que estão mudando nossa
forma de nos comunicarmos é bem óbvio né
mãe da gap tem tudo a ver com isso e se
concordam todo mundo já entendeu onde eu
vou chegar não né
eu explico você viaja na maionese nem
tudo vira ideia humorístico mas o tempo
toda a gente a gente faz conexões eu
gravei um vídeo de três minutos sobre
isso porque eu reparei uma coisa nesse
mundo que a gente está vivendo é eu
tenho acompanhado são 18 anos de
internet eu sou um sobrevivente quando
eu tô quase morrendo assim minha
carreira acabou em alguma coisa nova
esse ano foi o tube me deixar no youtube
foi bom meu parceiro ou então cheguei no
youtube com dez anos de atraso à
pirataria do material começou a falar eu
faço um desenho animado por dia com uma
pequena equipe
e lá no youtube é eu já estou com 24
milhões de visualizações mensais que é
mais do que muito o tubo famosão ea
gente está crescendo o número de
inscritos na mesa de três mil novos
inscritos dia então a gente vai chegar
logo a fazer muito barulho já é muito
legal
como tá e lá eu fiz um videozinho onde
eu tiro uma reflexão sobre essa era que
a gente está vivendo dos aplicativos o
impacto que têm na vida da gente
especialmente dos mais jovens porque eu
tenho acompanhado a evolução toda eu sou
do tempo do enem e meio lá no comecinho
né eu tô vendo todo esse conforto que as
redes sociais estão trazendo para a
nossa vida é e ao mesmo tempo todos os
riscos que das bolhas sociais daqueles
algoritmos que são escritos para nos
deixar em posições confortáveis que são
um perigo
que nos dão a sensação de maioria acho
que todos vocês sabem que quando vocês
estão por exemplo no na sua rede social
o que aparece pra você mesmo que a outra
pessoa curta que as mesmas pessoas que
você curtinha e resolveu seguir o que
vai aparecer pra você ali é
completamente personalizado porque tem a
ver com os seus joguinhos com seus
comentários tudo e isso te dá às vezes
até uma falsa sensação de hoje
unanimidade
você pensa que está no mundo mas na
verdade você está em uma bolha
voltando às redes sociais voltando os
aplicativos de mensagem e uma ainda gap
que começa a acontecer quando a gente
tem na mão um aplicativo onde você
conversa com a pessoa por texto escrito
e digitando através dos polegares né
aquele curso de digitação que se fazia
no passado da fotografia como quando que
os nossos avós e imaginar que um dia a
gente usar só os dois polegares para
conversar
obviamente ali já se falou muito sobre o
prejuízo diz pro idioma né porque você
vai comer os pronomes qualquer bebê ação
trabalhando a pena é o importante é se
comunicar
já tem muita gente defendendo que é a
língua
de acordo com a norma culta não é comum
no mundo deve ser cobrada está bem mais
flexível isso existe um outro problema
também que é o dos trabalhadores que não
se desligam porque eles estão 24 horas
por dia no artesanato eo chefe a me
lembrei fulô amanhã quando você chega e
manda essas 19 às 20 horas ou seja tem
gente já ganhou até processo em função
disso porque você não desliga tem
síndrome de burn out por causa daquilo
chega até um grau de destaque o horrível
mas tem uma outra coisa que eu reparei
que eu não vi ele falando eu falei isso
é um problema muito sério vou chamar a
atenção das pessoas para isso que há uma
guerra pe que é legal e omar também o
que mais tem em mente né e gap não é só
o espaço do buraco do degrau opep também
é qualquer espaço que também pode ser um
espaço de tempo
tanto que no mundo corporativo se usa
muito falar assim é existe um gap entre
o planejamento e o lançamento do produto
né a palavra chique de suzano para tvs
né
o que acontece quando a gente tá falando
por mensagem
a gente tá faltando mensagem você manda
uma mensagem espera a mensagem do outro
e vai naquela troca então pra aquelas
conversas são as conversas mais simples
do cotidiano você tem as respostas muito
fáceis muito fáceis mas quando são
respostas mais complexas ou quando um
xaveco uma relação afetiva que começando
e você quer sua inteligente e você quer
impressionar bem você tem uma coisa
muito boa ali naquele aplicativo que
você não tem no contato do convívio
social ou na ligação telefônica que é o
tempo para pensar uma resposta né que
sejam 30 segundos pra você falar e aí
tomar a a dizer que essa gatinha tal tem
30 segundos talvez um minuto 2 se você
tiver com pouca inspiração você pode
dizer que acabou seu crédito do 4g
o que você foi interrompido por alguém
mas enfim você tem o gap você usa guerra
a seu favor
existe um espaço de tempo que você usa
que está ali à sua disposição ea gente
vive num mundo que dá a gente entender
que não existe sequer piquet não existe
esse silêncio porque quando você entra
por exemplo venceu o youtube predileto o
vídeo dele é todo recortado reparou que
aqueles cortes secos assim todos os
silêncios todas as frases que ele diz
errada todos os momentos que ele
precisou de uma reflexão tac conversando
de repente ele esse espaço e corta né
você vai ver uma série hoje é muito mais
acelerada a tv acelerada tudo é
acelerado
todo mundo tem que ter resposta na ponta
da língua a nossa nossa querida monja né
vou perguntar pra ela o sentido da vida
ela pode com aquela tranqüilidade
budista
aí você desacelera junto e pronto mas a
vida real não nos dá isso a vida real é
tá nos cobrando cada vez mais a internet
à velocidade das coisas que a gente
tenha sempre uma resposta na ponta da
língua pronta a qualquer momento né
quando você está no aplicativo está lá
conversando com alguém na sua tentativa
de de sedução aparece a menina de
pergunta qual o seu filme predileto do
tarantino
você corre no google vê a filmografia do
tarantino inteira expostos que sorte que
eu vi que o bill em kill bill ao vivo ao
seu filme predileto tarantino
vou ao banheiro e vai pegar o google não
tem como né gente
então o que acontece muitos jovens da
geração de vocês estão aqui a maioria
jovens está preferindo esse tipo de
interação e fica muito desconfortável
quando tem que conversar ao vivo estou
falando uma besteira
quando o cara pede o telefone ou ela
pede o telefone e você vai ter que
passar por aquele segundo estágio que é
o estágio da conversa ao vivo ou de
chegar junto
o frio na barriga fica gigante por que
falar
a capacidade de verbalização ela é um
aprendizado é uma habilidade adquirida a
gente não nasce com ela imagina por
exemplo você numa entrevista de emprego
tá se você não utiliza isso você aprende
a lidar com isso
se você não aprendeu a lidar com esse
gap setala entrevista de emprego cara
que faz algumas perguntas que são
básicas e vem fácil com a sua idade
quantos filhos você tem você é casado
você já trabalhou com outros anos nessa
área
aí quando ele pensa assim onde você se
vê daqui a dez anos
se você tiver um aplicativos ainda pode
essa é aquela hora que fala acabou 4g eo
vizinho bateu na porta desculpa é né e o
relógio começa a contar quando aparece o
azulzinho né gente até a pressão vem até
nos aplicativos apareceu azulzinho viu
e tem gente fica altamente ansioso pela
resposta não vem né
mas ao vivo gente não tem isso a boa
notícia além dessa estou dizendo que
você pode desenvolver essa habilidade é
que esse gap nessa velocidade maluca que
estão impondo pra gente
ela é completamente desnecessária você
pode usar o silêncio você tem alguns
truques do discurso que pode usar a seu
favor quando você tiver uma situação
dessa de desconforto por exemplo é muito
difícil para um jovem dizer fala assim
não está lá ao vivo com seu filme do
tarantino predileto
nossa me deu um branco quais mesmo que
ele dirigiu tô nossa visão branco a ele
fez o que o bill django dá a entender
isso
a gente fica tão habituado com o gape ao
bep que a gente perde a capacidade do
improviso ou por exemplo se você está lá
na entrevista de emprego o cara pergunta
pra você onde você se vê daqui a dez
anos
você pode começar o que se olhar para o
teto foi lá onde eu me vejo daqui a dez
anos talvez vá te admirar porque vai ver
que você não quer o impossível que fala
primeira besteira na cabeça e você pode
deixar fluir fluir
desde que você não fala uma besteira
olha eu me vejo feliz e me vejo
estabelecido aí sou sério tá lá atrás em
segundo plano trabalhando resposta e
acho que posso conseguir tudo isso
trabalhando aqui com vocês né então o
que acontece é um aprendizado é um
aprendizado gente não tem como é eu
vendo essa placa mãe da gap
eu fiz esse vídeo onde eu chamei atenção
para isso
muito se fala sobre os prejuízos das da
desses pequenos componentes que
maravilha a gente mas que também são uma
invasão de privacidade terrível
não existe nada pior do que aquele cara
que está lá com você no aplicativo assim
foi pra mim tudo bem em você tá aí pra
mim pô cara escreve o que quer escreve
das linhas mas é ver é um texto aquilo
porque a mesma coisa você está
conversando com alguém esse plugin é tão
inclusivo quando você está conversando
com alguém alguém chegar enfiar a cara
no meio começou a conversar com você não
sabe onde você tá o que você está
fazendo tem nada disso
então essa geração está habituado a
conversar só por mensagens curtas e que
utilizando o bep ao seu favor
eu deixei recado mãe da gap preocupem se
tenha atenção cuidado com os espaços
vazios
aprendam a trabalhar ele no dia a dia eu
sei que a passagem que trazemos para
você não mensagens para transformar a
vida de vocês um sentido mais amplo mas
vai fazer muita diferença pra vocês no
mercado de trabalho nas relações
afetivas
à medida em que vocês aprenderem que
essa é uma habilidade e acreditem o
ilsinho na barriga nunca vai sumir o que
ele não precisa ser uma coisa pra se
mobilizar pra te paralisar
eu mesmo subir aqui falar por ted tem
regras aqui falando até de falar com
vocês numa outra cidade para ouvir é eu
quebrei um pouco a minha atenção
botar todo mundo pra cantar mas o
friozinho da barriga é meu amigo
o friozinho me ajuda não falar besteira
o friozinho pode ser domado então é só
isso vocês prestarem atenção no que está
sendo que está dizendo com atenção mas
tomar muito cuidado se você é usuário de
aplicativos de mensagens com esse gap
ainda bebe obrigada
[Aplausos]